Now to him that is of power to establish
you according to my gospel and the
preaching of Jesus Christ,
according to the revelation of the
mystery which was kept secret since the
beginning of the world, but now is made
manifest and by the scriptures and of
the prophets, according to the
commandment of the everlasting God, made
known unto all nations. for the
obedience of the faith. To God only wise
be glory forever through Jesus Christ.
Amen.
Amen. Welcome to Q&A on the word
inspired with Elder Randy Ski. Today we
are discussing the mystery of godliness.
Before we go any further, let's have a
word of prayer. Father, we invite your
presence here this afternoon. We thank
you for the space on your Sabbath day to
delve into this topic, the mystery of
godliness. Anoint your man's servant
with your holy anointing oil, oh God.
give him a double portion of your spirit
this afternoon and be with every
participant. Brother Israel, Sister
Chelsea, Brother Ashton, and all of
those that are joining via Zoom,
Facebook, YouTube, Instagram. May we,
dear Lord, know your mystery or at least
train our mind to study it and know you
from this time forth and even forever
more. In Jesus's name, amen. Amen. Amen.
Our special guest today is a man of God.
He is committed, consistent, faithful,
earnest in his calling, and a man of
study.
He completed his training at the Oakwood
University and the theological seminary
at Andrews University. And beyond
preaching to crowds, large churches,
small churches, he is intentional about
continuing relationships with people on
a personal level. And that's why I call
him and ask you to help me welcome Papa
or Elder Randy Skate.
Thank you my dear. God bless you so much
as always and this will always be the
case. I am honored truly am spiritually
and otherwise to be a part of this
ministry that has been a blessing to
many people in all four quarters of the
world. So thanks again for the
invitation. Ultimately I thank God for
the high honor of speaking for him and
representing him. Thank you very much.
Amen and amen. And I should also add
that you are a nice man. Well, every
Sabbath. Yes.
Amen. And amen.
So do you can we can even just go
straight into the questions. So we are
talking about the mystery of godliness
and the first question has three parts
but you may answer it in one string.
Namely, what is godliness?
What is a mystery? Mhm. And so then what
is the mystery of godliness? All right.
Well, godliness by itself would suggest
being like God
being not being like God in the sense of
being divine. No created being can be
divine but trying to to express the
character of God that is godliness. When
you speak of the mystery of godliness.
Now that of course existed before human
beings were made uh and asked to reflect
the charact of God. The mystery of
godliness is a very comprehensive term.
It includes the incarnation of Jesus
Christ. It includes his atonement. It
includes his mediatorial work he's doing
at the temple right now. All of that is
involved in the mystery of godliness.
what God has done for the salvation of
sinners and yet remain just while
justifying sinners. The way he did that,
that is all part of the mystery of
godliness because not even angels fully
understand it. That's why it will be the
subject of study throughout eternity. It
cannot be exhausted but must be studied.
Amen. Amen. Now a mystery by the way in
the Bible can be either something that
can never be known or something yet not
yet known. As we had the word mystery
occurs about six times in the book of
Ephesians more than any other book. I
think about five times in the first
Corinthians. A mystery is something that
can be made known or can be something
that cannot be known. But as far as the
gospel is concerned, the mystery of
godliness is something while it cannot
be exhausted, it can be incrementally
understood. As you study more and more,
God reveals more and more of this thing
called the mystery of godliness. Because
as we know him more clearly, our
relationship with him deepens. So a
mystery can either be something that
cannot be understood or something not
yet revealed.
And the gospel is a mystery in the sense
that it can never be fully exhausted,
but it is gradually gradually revealed
to us because we need to understand how
we're saved, how we're sustained, and
who our savior is and the cost of his
his sacrifice. But it cannot be
exhausted.
Amen. Amen. Amen. When God taught the
the gospel to Paul, according to
Galatians 1 11 and 12, God revealed him
the mystery, not in his absolute
fullness, but sufficient for him to
begin preaching that mystery. According
to Galatians 3:8, God preached the
gospel to Abraham. That was the mystery
of godliness. Abraham surely did not
know everything. He knew enough to teach
his family and to teach the surrounding
tribes among whom he lived.
Absolutely. Absolutely. You know, it's
so powerful. You know, uh, Papa Ski,
they were mentioning that we have to
still study the mystery. You know, this
is we're talking about Jesus, the plan
of salvation, his ministry, his life
work. This is the mystery of godliness,
becoming like God. As you said, not that
we are God or we would be divine in
terms of uh how can I say divinity in
the sense of Jesus's divinity or the
father's divinity, but as humanity, we
can be take partake of the divine
nature. Let's put it that way. By having
Christ in us, Christ is in you. The
divine nature is in you. It does not
make you divine. No created being can be
divine. But you can be possessed by
divine power. When you have Christ, you
have divine power in you. It's a human
being sustained by divine power.
Christ is a humanity was sustained by
divine power. His humanity was sustained
by divine power. But he had two natures.
Human, divine. The human wasn't divine.
The human was human. It was sustained by
divine power. We can be sustained by
divine power. Our humanity will never
become divinity. Never.
Amen. Amen. Amen. So, we're going to
move on to the next question. Or in
fact, maybe I'll just I can read let me
just read this quote here from
manuscript uh 114 the year 1898
paragraph 16. Ellen White says, "Christ
is the mystery of godliness.
God calls for humble reliance upon him.
His divine aid is promised in the holy
scriptures.
So now as we move on to the second
question, we already answered the first
part which was can the mystery of
godliness be revealed to humanity? You
mentioned that although we may not
understand all of it, we will spend all
eternity studying it. And so part of it
was revealed as you mentioned to
Abraham, to Paul. But then the question
is why should we study the mystery of
godliness? Especially since we won't
find out all about it ever. Well, you
don't need to find out all about it. If
you do, then God ceases to be God. So,
we cannot find out. But the Bible tells
us in uh John 17:3.
And this is life eternal that they might
know thee, the only true God and Jesus
Christ whom thou has sent. We have to
know our savior. We read in Matthew
11:28, "Come unto me all ye that labor
and are heavy laden. I will give you
rest. Take my yoke upon you and learn of
me. Jesus tells us learn of me. To learn
of Jesus. Elise says he is the mystery
of godliness. Absolutely he is. He is
the embodiment of the mystery of
godliness. We learn of him. He did not
say exhaust all the knowledge that I
possess. He says learn of me and we
learn more and more of him gradually. So
we're called by our savior who embodies
the mystery of godliness to learn about
him. And that knowledge as it enters us
will transform us, strengthen us,
elevate us, make us more and more like
God. Understanding we will never reach
the point where we are God. That is
absolutely impossible. We won't even
come close because God is so different
and so high. But we can grow and grow.
Second uh Peter 3:18, grow in grace and
in the knowledge of our Lord and Savior
Jesus Christ. And this growth must be
unending.
It begins here. It continues in the new
world. And so yes, we have to study the
mystery of godliness that we may know
how to align our lives more and more
with the standards of heaven. Because
God has one standard. He's the one that
functions in heaven. It also is required
of those of us on the earth who call
ourselves children of God.
Amen. Amen. Amen. Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you, Paposki, for breaking that
down for us. So, we are going to move
swiftly along. I'm going to invite
brother Israel Amuzu and please correct
me, brother Israel, if I have
mispronounced your last name, please uh
to ask the next three questions. He's
joining us all the way from Ghana. Ghana
is a good place. I've been there about
seven times. God bless Ghana.
Amen. Amen.
Cameroon and Ivory Coast and Kenya and
Tanzania and Algeria and South Africa.
God bless all of Africa. Amen. Amen.
Amen.
All right. So, God bless you, pastor,
and God bless.
Amen. Amen. Now, the next set of
questions um has to deal with the roles.
What roles do the Holy Spirit play? And
so we are taken from 1 Corinthians 10 uh
2:10 through13 and Ephesians chapter 3
verse 5 and it reads that but God hath
revealed them unto us by his spirit. For
the spirit search all things yay the
deep things of God. For what man knoweth
the things of a man, save the spirit of
man which is in him? Even so the things
of God knoweth no man, but the spirit of
God. Now we have received not the spirit
of the world but the spirit which is of
God that we might know the things that
are freely given to us of God. And
Ephesians 3:5 says which things also we
speak not in the words which man's
wisdom teacheth but which the Holy Ghost
teacheth comparing spiritual things with
spiritual. Mhm. And the question is,
what roles do the Holy Spirit and the
study of God's word play in unlocking
the mystery of godliness? Very good
question. You cannot separate the Holy
Spirit from the word of God. And it is
through the word of God we learn about
the mystery of godliness. Of course,
when the when that plan was developed
between the father and the son, long
ago, there was no Bible. But the Bible
is the revealed will of God. Matter of
fact, Ellaw White says Jes Jesus
actually is God's thoughts made audible
and his words are found in the Bible.
You cannot separate the spirit of God
from the word of God because one of his
titles is he is the spirit of truth. Now
here is what Jesus said in John 16:13.
How be it, when he, the spirit of truth,
is come, he will guide you into all
truth. One of the functions of the Holy
Ghost, the Holy Spirit, the third member
of the Godhead, is to guide us into
truth. By that I mean cooperate with our
efforts to understand. We must make an
effort to understand. The Holy Ghost
combines his power with that effort and
reveals to us the things of truth. And
so to understand the mystery of
godliness, we need the involvement and
leadership of the Holy Spirit. Not only
that, but the benefits of the atonement
of Jesus Christ are mediated to us
through the Holy Spirit. The work of
sanctification is led by the Holy
Spirit. And we know from 1 Thessalonians
4:3, this is the will of God, even your
sanctification. And so the Holy Spirit
is the divine instrument by which the
the secrets of the mystery of godliness
are revealed to the student who makes an
effort to study and find out. You cannot
separate the spirit of God from the word
of God. And you cannot separate the
spirit of God from the mystery of
godliness because the mystery of
godliness is mentioned in the word of
God. Without the spirit of God, we will
guide ourselves into error
of the spirit. He is the one who teaches
us the things of truth. But as I said,
we must make a concentrated effort to
study the word and the spirit blesses
our efforts. There's a remarkable
example of this in the book of Daniel
chapter 8. Daniel heard one angel saying
to another one being saying to another
unto 2,300 days, then shall the
sanctuary be cleansed. Daniel 8:14
verses 15 and 16 tell us, "And it came
to pass when I, even I, Daniel, had seen
the vision and sought for the meaning,
then behold, they stood before me as the
appearance of a man." The Bible says
Daniel saw the vision and sought for the
meaning. He wanted to understand. He
tried. And I heard a man's voice verse
16 between the banks of Uli which called
and said Gabriel make this man to
understand the vision. So we have
someone trying to understand then we
have help from above to assist him which
means not only the Holy Ghost helps us
but angels also help us in understanding
truth and the angels are under the
direction and the command of the Holy
Spirit in that endeavor. And so I say
again for the third time, you cannot
remove the Holy Spirit from the truth,
the word of God. You cannot remove the
Holy Ghost, from the mystery of
godliness. Remove him, you and I will
understand nothing of God.
Amen. Amen. Amen. And the sacrifice of
Christ, the merits of the sacrifice
could not be applied to us because that
application is done by the spirit of
God. Amen. Amen. I'm very sorry. Let me
make this correction. I read um
Ephesians chapter 3 verse 5 and it says
which in other ages was not made known
unto the sons of men as it is now
revealed unto his holy apostles and
prophet by the spirit. All right. Now
let's go. Which in time past was not
made known.
Let's go to first Peter uh chapter 1.
Okay. First Peter chapter one.
Let's read from verse
9.
First Peter 1 verse 9. Verse 9. It says
receiving the end of your faith, even
the salvation of your souls. The word
end of your faith doesn't mean the
conclusion. It means the ultimate
objective of faith is salvation. We're
only saved by faith. or the end of your
faith. May the overall purpose, the
overall objective of your what is the
end? What is the purpose? To what
purpose? Your salvation. Keep reading.
And verse 10, it says, "Of salvation the
prophet have inquired and searchth
diligently, who prophesied of the grace
that should came should come unto you."
Now notice verse 10. Of with salvation
the prophets inquired in search. They
did not understand what they were
writing. They were just writing. Did not
understand. Verse 11. Searching what or
what manner of time the spirit of Christ
which was in them did signified when it
testified beforehand the sufferings of
Christ and the glory that shall follow.
Now they did not fully understand. Now
read verse 12.
Verse 12. unto whom it was revealed that
not unto themselves, but unto us
minister the thing which are now
reported unto you by them.
Some they were told, they were told,
listen, you're writing things that apply
to a future generation. Now, the gospel
applies to all ages, but certain aspects
of the gospel, the literal coming of
Christ did not apply to the Old
Testament. It applied to the New. So
they're writing things, the sufferings
of Christ apply to the new, not to the
old. You know, the work of Pentecost
applied to the new, not to the old. And
so they were writing about things that
would not happen in their lifetime. And
they could not understand.
Now we understand. It is now revealed by
the spirit's apostles. And now we
understand, not everything, but we
understand more now than even the
prophets then understood. So when you
read Ephesians 3:5 which in other ages
was not made known you understand when
they wrote the understanding was very
limited. We have a much broader
understanding why because the savior
himself came and he lived on earth and
so that provided a clearer expression of
who God is and this thing called the
mystery of godliness. People who saw
Christ were looking at the mystery of
godliness. They never had that chance.
In the old, they looked at sheep and
cows and goats or whatever else. But in
the new, people looked at Christ, the
mystery of godliness. And so it was now
revealed more fully.
More fully. The old testament people
weren't ignorant, but they did not have
the bright light that we have in the
new.
All right? So long to come.
Amen. Amen. Now the next question has to
do with Romans 16 25- 27. Let's quickly
read. It says, "Now to him that is of
power to establish you according to my
gospel and the preaching Christ
according to the revelation of the
mystery which was kept secret since the
world began. But now is made manifest
and by the scriptures of the prophets
according to the commandments of the
everlasting God made known to all
nations for the obedience of faith. The
God only wife be glory through Jesus
Christ forever. Amen. Amen. And the
question is twofold.
Sure. The question is twofold um
questions. And it says Paul names the
manifestation of the mystery to all
nations and necessary condition for the
obedience of faith. Now the first
question is what is the obedience of
faith? And the other question is why is
the manifestation of the mystery a
necessary condition for the obedience of
faith? Faith is based on the word of
God. Now faith that's attached to
salvation must be an intelligent faith.
God calls no one to serve him out of
absolute ignorance. Various people have
various levels of knowledge. But God
requ faith requires some degree of
knowledge. Not all but some degree of
knowledge or evidence. And so in order
then to express faith, faith would be
based on the word of God. Without the
word of God, you cannot have faith.
Romans 10:17, faith cometh by hearing
and hearing by the word of God. Faith
and the word of God are inseparable. The
obedience of faith is the obedience
based on the word of God. When we learn
about Christ, when we know what he came
to do for us, when we understand these
things to whatever level we can, that if
we accept it genuinely produces in us a
response, that response is the response
of faith. And faith is only alive if it
produces obedience. So we have the
obedience of faith. Faith, you see, when
someone is justified by faith, it
converts the mind to an obedient mind.
It doesn't just simply make you right in
God's presence. You cannot be you cannot
have a right standing with God with a
disobedient mind because God's focus is
the mind, not your elbows on your knees.
To have a right relationship with God, a
right standing is to have the right
attitude. So your mind is renewed and
you're given an obedient mind. And like
the Apostle Paul, your first question
is, Lord, what will thou have me to do?
Let me say it again. Justification by
faith produces a change in the mind. The
spirit renews the mind. You go from
rebellion to obedience. You go from a
rebel to a child of God willing to do
whatever God says. The obedience of
faith is the response to the truth.
And the the the carnal truth, right, the
kernel of that truth, the heart and soul
of that truth is the incarnation of
Christ
and the sacrifice he made that sinners
might be saved and God still remains
just and his law is satisfied.
When that comes to us, it produces
obedience. I want to do whatever he says
if he did all of that for me.
Amen. Amen. God bless you. That's an
amazing. That means there can never be
any faith separated from God's word. You
cannot get you cannot separate the word
and faith. If the word goes, faith goes.
Faith cometh by hearing, hearing by the
word of God. A lot of people say, "I
believe by belief as though it's some
sort of abracadabra, open sesame." No,
no, no, no. Faith must be intelligent. A
person doesn't have to know everything
to have faith, but that person must know
something. The Bible doesn't begin with
an invitation, believe in me. The Bible
begins with what God has done, creation.
Then we're called to believe in him. So
the Bible begins with evidence or with
proof or I say evidence. Here's what God
has done. This is the being telling you,
believe in me. Why should you believe?
Look at what I've done. So your faith is
based on information. Not all that's
available, but enough for an honest
person to respond by faith.
Amen. Amen. Faith is possible to please
God by grace. I say through faith,
consequently, you have to have the word
of God. Wherever faith exists, the word
of God exists.
Amen. Amen. Amen.
Now the next question is Paul delineates
the mystery of godliness in 1 Timothy
3:16 which says and without controversy
great is the mystery of godliness God
was manifest in the flesh justified in
the spirit seen of angels preached unto
the Gentiles believed on in the world
received up in the glory
question the first question is twofold
question. It says that first he mentions
that God was manifest in the flesh and
so the question is how was God manifest
in the flesh? All right. And the other
question is what does that mean for our
salvation?
All right. What does it mean that God
was manifest in the flesh? Now, no one
can see God and live. God told that to
Moses in Exodus 33:18 to20. You cannot
see my face and live. But the Bible says
Moses saw the face of God. Moses came
closer than anyone else. But Moses did
not see the literal face of God. You
cannot see the face of God with a carnal
nature and lived. And even though Moses
was God's special servant, Moses still
possessed the carnal nature. Only when
this corruptible puts on incorruption
will we be able to look into the face of
God. So no sinner, however, no saint,
however holy he or she may be, can look
into the face of God, even though all
that person's sins are forgiven as long
as that person still possesses the
carnal nature. God was manifest in the
flesh. God had to come to us. You see,
only God can save us. A human being can
understand what we're going through and
God can do something about it. A human
being cannot save a human being. A
divine being can save a human being, but
a human being understands a human being.
Christ came as both. So he clothed his
divinity in humanity.
How that came about is a mystery. No one
can fully understand how the mighty God
whom the Bible says existed from
everlasting to everlasting. The one who
said let there be light. The one before
angels veil their faces. The the the the
everlasting father. How
can divinity
be hidden in humanity? But when Christ
came to this earth, God came to the
earth. Go to Matthew chapter 1. Let's
read verse 21 and 23. Well, let's read
23. In 21, the angel tells Joseph, "She
shall bring forth a son. Thou shalt call
his name Jesus, for he shall save his
people from their sins." Now read verse
23 of Matthew 1 and see something
similar to God was manifest in the
flesh. Matthew 1:23. Behold, behold the
virgin shall be with child. Yes. And
shall bring forth a son. Uhhuh. They
shall call his name Emmanuel, which
being interpreted is God with us. Yes.
God with us. Same thing. So we're told
twice, "And in the mouth of two or three
witnesses, every word shall be
established." God. You know, it's a
mystery. It came to us. Those who looked
into the face of Jesus were looking into
the face of the one who said, "Let there
be light." But behind that face was the
fullness, the glory of a divine being,
which human beings could not tolerate.
And so God came, but mysteriously his
divinity was hidden by his um humanity.
Now, let's go to Acts chapter 20. Let's
see that again. Acts 20. Let's read
verse 28. Paul is talking to the
Ephesian elders. His final words to
them. They'll never see him again.
Here's what he tells them. Verse 28.
First, he tells them 25 to 27. He has
told them everything. He has not
hesitated. So he has no blood on his
hands. Now listen to his words in verse
28.
Take heed therefore unto yourselves
and to all the flock over the which the
Holy Ghost have made you overseers
to feed the church of God which feed
purchased to feed which church? The
church of God. Notice that the church of
God. Now keep reading. Which he has
purchased with his own blood. Now God
purchased the church with his own blood.
Wait, but God is a spirit. You follow
me? A spirit doesn't bleed. Jesus said,
"A spirit hath not flesh and bones." And
so this God became human. So in his
humanity, he can shed his blood. In his
divinity, he had the power to save. And
so the church of God, which he hath
purchased with his own blood. Now go to
1 John chapter 3. Let's read verse 16. 1
John chapter 3 verse 16. We answer the
question, what is meant by uh divinity?
Uh God was manifest in the flesh. 1 John
3:16. Hereby perceive we the love of
God. Thereby perceive we the love of God
because he laid down his life for us and
we to lay down our lives for the brelin.
Now wait a minute. Who laid down our
lives for us? Who laid down his life for
us? God. That's what the verse said.
Thereby perceive we the love of God
because he laid down his life. It was
God in human form who died. I'm not
saying divinity died. I'm saying
mysteriously God took on a form that
allowed death. He in his humanity he
died. Hereby perceive we the love of God
because he laid down his life for us.
This is the part of the mystery of
godliness. God was manifest in the
flesh. And so all we can say is somehow
someway God devised a way for him to
come in human form which meant he had to
eat, he had to drink, he had to sleep,
he cried, he was tired, he could bleed
all of that because he was human via his
humanity he could give up his life for
us. But that's the of mysteries.
Amen. And John 14, the word was made
flesh. The word was Yeah. The word was
made flesh. Yes. Yes. The word who was
God. According to John 1:1, in the
beginning was the word and the word was
myth God and the word was God and the
word became flesh. Yes. Now, as much as
the divinity is purely divinity, the
humanity was full humanity as well. We
can't lessen the humanity. Absolutely.
As much as he was divine, he was human.
But again, it is the mystery of
mysteries. But we must study it. Now,
what was the second question? I didn't
get to the second question. What was
this? The second question says, what
does that mean for our salvation? Okay,
very good. What does it mean for
salvation? In his in his humanity,
Christ endured temptation. He could
sympathize. You see, he's a sympathizing
savior. He could sympathize. The Bible
says, "We have not an high priest which
cannot be touched with the feeding of
our infirmities, but was in all points
tempted like as we are, yet without
sin." Hebrews 4:15.
Hebrews 2:14, "For as much then as the
children are partakers of flesh and
blood, he also himself likewise took
part of the same, that through death he
might destroy him that had the power of
death." Death was an essential part of
the atonement that life had to be given
up. But it could not be given up if he
had been purely divine. Divinity cannot
die. 1 Timothy 6:16, who only have
immortality, so the human side permitted
death to be experienced. And so Christ
came in human form. He experienced
temptation. He experienced harassment
from the devil. He was he had a
difficult life. He suffered. He was
abused. He took all of that. All of that
was necessary to save us. It was
essential for him to be abused. It was
essential for him to be mocked. It was
essential for him to be tempted. All of
that was essential. Without if any of
those pieces had been missing, the the
torment, the plan of salvation would not
be complete. The death was essential. Of
course, he voluntarily gave up his life.
But whether you give it up or someone
kills you, death is death. Are you
following me? He gave up his life. Then
he rose. All of that
was necessary for you. See, a dead Jesus
cannot save you. And so he had to come
back from the grave via he went down in
his humanity via the power of divinity.
He came back again a mystery we cannot
explain, but the Bible says it happened.
destroy this temple in three days I will
raise it up. Jesus said in John 2 I
believe verse 19. And so without that
mystery of human and divine mixing we
could not be saved. God does nothing
just for doing it. He does things for a
purpose. And the purpose of the mystery
of godliness was twofold. To show the
universe the glory of God and to provide
a way of salvation for us. Ultimately,
our salvation will bring honor and glory
to God's name. Ultimately, I say that
because we must not think our salvation
is the highest priority. The glory of
God is the highest priority. The
salvation of sinners was one way for God
to receive all the final glory that he
deserves.
Amen. Amen. Behold the lamb of God that
taketh away the sins of the world.
Amen. Amen. Amen. God bless you, Elder
Ski. God bless you. Now I'm going to seg
you. Amen. Seg you to
Thank you so much, brother Israel and
Elder Rainey Ski. Brother Israel, thank
you for joining despite the blackout
that is taking place right now in Ghana.
God bless you. Sorry about that. God
bless you. God bless you.
All right. So, we are moving swiftly
along. This is question six.
What is the relationship between the
mystery of godliness and the gospel of
Jesus? This question is inspired by
Ephesians chapter 3:es 2 and 3 and
Galatians 1:12. And I could read that if
you like, Papa. Yes. Go ahead. Go ahead.
So Ephesians chapter 3. And Lord, we
just continue to ask for your Holy
Spirit and guidance as we delve into
your word. Use your man's servant, dear
Lord, today in Jesus's name. Amen. Read
from verse one. Yes. Ephesians chapter 3
verse one. Mhm. For this cause I, Paul,
the prisoner of Jesus Christ for you
Gentiles, if ye have heard of the
dispensation of the grace of God, which
is given me to you, word, how that by
revelation
he made known unto me the mystery, as I
wrote a four in few words, whereby when
ye read, ye may understand my knowledge
in the mystery of Christ. Mhm. So that's
Ephesians 3:es 1-4.
Now we're going to read of the words
that Paul spoke of a four time. Mhm. So
this is Galatians 1 11 and 12. But I
certify you, brethren, that the gospel
which was preached of me is not of man.
For I neither received it of man,
neither was I taught it, but by the
revelation of Jesus Christ. Yes. Mhm.
Now
we had a quotation from Ellaw White.
Christ is the mystery of godliness.
Christ is ourselves. In 1 Corinthians
1:30, let's go there for a while. 1
Corinthians 1:30. See what Christ is
comprehensively.
But of him are ye in Christ Jesus who of
God is made unto us wisdom, wisdom, and
righteousness and sanctification and
redemption. Jesus is to us wisdom,
righteousness, sanctification,
redemption. So Elawite is right when she
says he is the mystery of godliness.
Christ is the gospel. You want to put
Elli said he was both the law and the
gospel. I think it's Christ triumphant
page 339 paragraph 2. Christ was both
the law and the gospel. Of course, you
cannot separate the law from the gospel.
And so the connection between the
mystery of godliness and the gospel is
that the mystery of godliness, the
gospel is the preaching of the mystery
of godliness. It is the good news of
what God has arranged for our salvation.
And so in certain ways we've already
gone over that question of repetition is
effective form of teaching.
Paul tells us the mystery was revealed
to him. We must not assume from that he
was told everything. He was told enough
to reach the Gentiles who knew very very
little about God. The Jews had a
tremendous advantage. They had the law.
They had the prophets and all the
writing. The Gentiles had virtually
nothing. So Paul, God revealed enough to
Paul to reach the Gentiles. So when Paul
says which was revealed to me, he is not
suggesting everything about the mystery
of godliness was told to him, his mind
couldn't take it, but enough for him to
inform the Gentiles that they might come
to Jesus Christ. And so the preaching of
the gospel is the preaching of the
mystery of godliness. what God has done
to save those who cannot save
themselves, just cannot save themselves.
Regardless of the levels of education
and experience and training, no one can
save himself or herself. It is through
the mystery of godliness, the preaching
of that, the preaching of the gospel is
the preaching of the mystery of
godliness. The mystery is also seen
expressed by Jesus this way. The wind
bloweth where it listeth, and thou
hearest the sound thereof, but can not
tell whence it cometh, or whether it
goeth. So is everyone that is born of
the spirit. John 3:8. Mysterious. You
cannot tell. You see the evidence. You
see the fruit. You see the results, but
you cannot explain it. All of that is
part of the mystery. And so the gospel
is the declaration, the proclamation of
the mystery of godliness as it applies
to the salvation of souls.
Amen. Amen. Very well put. Praise the
Lord. Also, keep in mind the mystery of
godliness is also for the benefit of the
angels. Go to Ephesians chapter 3. Let's
read verse 9 and verse 10. Yes. Yes.
and to make all men see what is the
fellowship of the mystery
which from the beginning of the world
hath been hidden God who created all
things by Jesus Christ to the intent
that now unto the principalities and
powers in heavenly places might be known
the church and the manifold wisdom read
that again might be known known by the
church.
Yes. Oh, sorry. Might be known by the
church the manifold wisdom of God. Which
introduces another consideration. Now,
God revealed the mystery to Paul to
preach to the Gentiles. God revealed the
mystery to Abraham, Genesis 3:8, so that
he might speak to those with whom he
lived 2,000 years earlier. But now, the
angels also need to understand elements
of this mystery.
God uses the church
as the mystery works in the church.
Angels begin to understand elements of
this mystery they previously did not
understand and to make call to the
intent that now unto the principalities
and powers in heavenly places might be
known by the church the manifold wisdom
of God. When we allow that mystery to
work in us and we're faithful to God and
our lives are transformed, angels learn
something about the plan of salvation.
Angels learn something about the mystery
of godliness. Ellite tells us by coming
to dwell with us, Christ was to reveal
God both to men and to angels.
Uh I think that's of ages page 19
paragraph 2. by coming to dwell with us.
Jesus was to reveal God the Father, both
the human being and to angels.
When the plan of salvation was put in
effect, the angels began to learn about
God things they never knew before. M and
so yes uh the mystery of godliness and
the plan of salvation it benefits
sinners and it benefits unfallen angels
because Ellen White tells us there
angels in heaven unfallen angels who
still were sympathetic to Satan until
the events of the cross then they
finally cut off all ties of sympathy. is
an astonishing thing. Up until for
thousands of years, they watched what he
did but still felt he had been unfairly
treated. The last tags of sympathy were
cut when they saw what he did to Christ
on that cross. And so angels needed to
learn and still need to learn. That is
why the cherubims are represented as
hovering over the mercy seat looking
down trying to understand how justice
and mercy function together seamlessly.
Amen. Amen. You know, as you were
speaking and you had me read Ephesians
3:es 9 and 10, I also thought about
first Peter 1:12. You know, how the
angels desire to look into these things.
You know, praise God. And that's a
mystery in itself. God can use us clay.
Yes. Teach angels about himself. What a
God. Second Corinthians chapter 3:3. We
are epistles
written by by by God, ministered by us,
written by the Holy Spirit. We are
epistles which not only people read, but
the angels read. We're spectacle to men
and to angels. That's what the Bible
says. So when we're faithful to the
message of the gospel, the angels see
what they need to see. When we're
unfaithful, we may confuse them. So we
need to be sure the gospel is working in
us that we may be sort of labs in which
the angels can learn how this gospel
work. We are living labs. Amen. Amen.
And I'm just going to underscore what
you mentioned in your response which is
God's mystery should be revealed in us.
In us. Mhm.
How a sinner can live a victorious life
is a mystery.
Mhm. It's a mystery.
There are some people whose lives have
been so profoundly changed by God. Even
their relatives don't understand.
Their friends cannot understand. This is
not the same person I knew. And that's
true. This person has been changed.
Unfortunately, that happens very
infrequently.
Elise says the new birth is very rare in
this age. She wrote that 100 years ago.
It's worse now. Mercy. Mhm. All right.
Next question.
At least twice. Yes. Paul mentions that
the mystery of God was hidden before or
since the world but is now manifested.
We saw that in 1 Corinthians chapter
2:7. We read it in Romans 16 25 and 26.
And he also even mentioned it when
speaking or alluded to it when speaking
about Abraham Papa.
So how was the mystery of godliness
encrypted or symbolized
before Christ's incarnation?
Well, the uh the system God used to
teach the mystery of godliness or
salvation, redemption, how God deals
with sin was a sanctuary system. That's
what he gave the Israelites. So he told
them, "Let them make me a sanctuary that
I may dwell among them." God doesn't
dwell there. Sin through this system, I
will deal with the thing that keeps you
and me apart. The thing that created
separation, which is sin. So the whole
book of Leviticus actually one word uh
summarizes that book which is holiness
which is the removal of sin. And so the
sanctuary system which is the uh the the
the the symbolic expression of the
gospel at every level every uh
microscopic detail of the sanctuary
contributes to our understanding of the
gospel or the mystery of godliness. And
so yes back then they had the sanctuary
system. When Christ came that was
abolished now they had Christ himself.
They had him the actual lamb. Now we
must still study that system to
understand what it teaches because the
lessons do not perish. There's a
different dispensation but the lessons
do not perish. And so we must study what
is meant by the the the Passover. 1
Corinthians 5:7 Jesus our Passover is
crucified for us. You know what was
Pentecost symbolized by you know in the
New Testament? What about you know the
feast of tabernacles? What about the day
of atonement? What about the feast of
trumpets? you know where what do these
things teach us and we need to study
those feasts and the sacrificials not
just a feast the sacrificial system to
learn about salvation that's why David
says thy way oh God is in the sanctuary
who is so great a god as our god your
way is in the sanctuary most churches
don't study it God has blessed this
church with an understanding of the
sanctuary system so yes the sanctuary
was the way by which the the the mystery
was unveiled
to the people back then, but it was
still not as bright as it became when
Jesus Christ himself came.
No sheep can fully represent Jesus
Christ. All the Old Testament people had
were sheep and goats and cows, whatever
else. No cow, no sheep, no bullock, no
turtle love, no pigeon, no sparrow can
reflect Jesus. When he came, we had, as
we say in Michigan, the real McCoy,
the real thing when Jesus Christ came.
But the Old Testament had its way and
that was the sanctuary system.
Amen. And he or she who does not
understand the sanctuary system cannot
fully understand the gospel. Or what
Christ is doing now. You cannot
understand what that's why Jesus said in
John 5, the last verse, if you don't
believe what Moses wrote, how can you
believe me? You say, So to understand
Christ's words, even though he was the
great light, you must understand the Old
Testament indispensable.
Despite the fact that many churches say
we're New Testament churches, we're not
Old Testament church. Jesus said to
understand the New Testament words which
he spoke, you must understand and
believe what Moses wrote.
Amen. Amen. Amen. Thank you, Papa Ski.
So we have about 10 more minutes left
for some open forum questions. Mhm. Uh
this question is from Kenny in India
which submitted about six days ago.
Okay. He wants us to explain this part
of the mystery of godliness. Mhm. And I
quote, "Please explain this seemingly
contradictory belief that we have as
Adventists." They say that if the church
had accepted the message of
righteousness by faith in 1888, then
Christ would have come around that time
to take us home or something to the
effect. If the church had gotten its act
right long back then Christ would come
to take us home. Doesn't that then mean
that those of us who were born much
later would not have been here there? If
so, then why would we want that? Please
explain this part of the mystery of
godliness. But if you if you well let's
pray again. Father, as I continue
fellowshipping with your people and
representing you, speak through me dear
God. In Jesus name I pray. Amen. That
argument can create a situation in which
Christ never comes because people get
being born. If he comes today, those who
might have been born in 226 would not be
saved. You can take that on at
infinitumal. The simple fact is Christ
has to come at some point. It cannot be
an indefinite delay of his coming. Yes.
Elawite writes, "If the word had been
taken, the message righteous by faith
and the church had gone with it, Christ
would have come." Yes. If the
Israelites, now we have a similar event
in the Old Testament. If the Israelites
had obeyed God, they would not have
spent 40 years in the wilderness. They
did not obey God. They did not trust his
word. And the delay was a curse God
placed on them. We may be under similar
curse.
Because of a lack of faith in the plain
word of God, we are still in the
wilderness of this world.
Wow. We can't say if he had come then I
would not have been saved. You wouldn't
know anything. I mean, you just wouldn't
exist.
That argument has to be very carefully
managed because it would have Christ
staying in heaven forever because people
will keep being born unless the human
race were wiped out. He has to come.
But from our perspective, there has been
a delay.
Yes.
Yes. So our next question and thank you
Paposki. Our next question comes from
brother Brendan Gilbert and I believe
you actually touched on this. All right.
So he says after his resurrection,
Christ maintained his humanity. Yes.
While on earth his divin was his excuse
me while on earth his divinity was
limited and that's a question mark
limited by slashhidden within that
humanity or his omnipresence. He was
subject to human weakness. Yes. So his
question is is the resurrected Christ so
too limited? So in terms of omnipresence
and is there any difference between the
pre-incarnate and the post ascension
Christ?
The pre-incarnate Christ was not human
which is a spirit. The post ascension
Christ was human and divine. That's a
vast difference. Let's let's simplify
those terms for those who don't
understand. Post ascension
pre-incarnate. Pre-incarnate means
before Christ came to this earth before
he took on human flesh. Incarnate means
to take on human flesh. Pre-incarnate,
before he did that, eons and eons ago,
before the worlds were made, Christ was
a spirit. He wasn't called Christ, just
the second member of the Godhead. That's
one state. Now, when he came to this
earth in human form, he lived, he died,
he rose. Now, the post-resurrection
Christ, I mean Christ after he rose is
different in the sense that he had human
nature now and still has it. He did not
have human form. The pre-incarnate did
not have human nature or human form. He
was just a spirit, just divine. That's
it. He took on human form. When he rose,
he took that human form to heaven with
him. It still has it, but it was a
glorified body. Let's go see uh
Philippians chapter 3. Let's read from
verse 19. Philippians 3 19. No, 20 20
and 21. the kind of post-resurrection
body that Jesus had.
For our conversation is in heaven and
the word conversation there means
citizenship.
Yes. Mhm. From whence also we look for
the savior, the Lord Jesus Christ. Now
listen very carefully. Who shall change
our vile body? What does vile mean in
that verse? Notice now Paul is saying
us. So he's talking about Christians,
the redeemed, those who've conquered
sin. How can they have a vile body? What
does he mean by vile? A corruptible
body, one that's subject to death. You
see, subject to sickness. That's what
vile. Not sinful, but subject to disease
and death and whatever else. He'll
change our vile bodies. Keep reading.
That it may be fashioned like unto his
glorious body. Ah, this is the body with
which he rose.
This go to Romans chapter 6, read verse
5.
For if we have been four and five,
sorry, four and five. Yes. Therefore, we
are buried with him by baptism into
death. Mhm. That like as Christ was
raised up from the dead, by the glory of
the father, that the glory of that's why
it's a glorified by the glory of the
father. Keep reading now. Even so, we
also should walk in newness of life.
That verse tells us Christ came back
from the by the raised by the glory of
the father. That's how we will be
raised. You see the same body he had.
Ephesians 3 20:21 is the body we will
have. Now I'm still dealing with
pre-incarnate and post-resurrection.
The pre-incarnate Christ did not have a
body. He was not called Christ. Christ
means Messiah, anointed one. That's his
office. Long before he was sin, there
was no need for a Christ. It is just the
second member of the godhead. When he
came to this earth, he took human form.
When he died, he came back from the
grave with a glorified body which is the
one we will have when we rise from the
grave. So that's the difference. Amen.
Right now Christ still has human form.
Consequently,
he has laid aside his omnipresence.
There are three distinguishing features
we always mention. Omnipotence,
omniscience, omnipresent. Omnipotence
mean all powerful omniscience all
knowing omnipresent everywhere at the
same time Christ cannot be everywhere at
the same time now because he still has
human form I didn't say he lost his
omnipresence he laid it aside Christ a
divine being can't lose equality are you
with me he has laid it aside doesn't use
it because he's voluntarily taken on
human form and we'll have it forever
it's part of the tremendous cost of our
salvation that a divine being will lay
aside stop using that he may continue to
look like those whom he came to save.
Amen. Amen. You know, Papaskki, as you
were answering this question, the Holy
Spirit was saying, "This is why this is
the mystery of godliness." Yes. And this
is why we can continue to study the plan
of salvation, the work of Christ for an
eternity, you know. Yes. Yes. Yes. Okay.
All right. Our next question comes from
Watch and Pray 2.0. Watch and pray. Can
God's people become the latter reign?
Say that again. Can God's people become
the latter reign? God's people cannot
become the latter rain. The latter rain
is the Holy Spirit. The Holy Spirit is
power. The former reign was a
dramatically demonstrated at Pentecost.
Acts chapter 2. The latter rain will be
a tremendously greater expression of the
spirit of God to enable the loud cry to
have its effect. The loud cry is come
out of her my people. That must be
backed up with power that the world has
never seen. That power will allow people
to be released from the bondage of error
and come where the truth is. The l no
people are the latter rain. They are
empowered by the latter rain. The holy
spirit. The latter rain is the holy
spirit. I cannot be the holy spirit.
People cannot be the holy spirit. The
latter rain refers to the work of the
Holy Spirit in the last days to give
power to the loud cry. So the answer is
no. People cannot be the latter rain.
But people are empowered by the latter
rain to preach the loud cry which has
come out of her my people. Her being
Babylon, the people being those willing
to obey God's commandments instead of a
man-made law.
Amen. Amen. So when the government says
Sunday is the day of worship and the
Bible says the seventh day and the call
is made come out of churches that insist
on following a man-made law. The latter
will give power to that message so
people will come out because it's not
easy to bring people out of error. It is
not easy particularly if they've grown
up in generations in error. It is not
easy. There must be a special pouring
out of power to break them free from the
shackles of error that they may come to
the truth.
So people are not the latter rain.
People are used by the Holy Spirit.
Amen. Yes. We receive the latter rain.
Praise the Lord. Yep. Now the latter
rain may be falling on individuals right
now. Not globally as it will happen. But
this person, that person, that person,
it certainly is, but at one point it
will fall on the church as a whole.
That they may preach come out of her
mighty.
The latter falls on those who making use
of the early rain, the former rain. In
other words, you're doing all you can
now for God. The latter end falls on
you, not on lazy people who are
somewhere in a hammock or couch waiting
for the latter rain to do something. The
latter falls on those who've shown he
that is faithful in that which is least.
The early rain is faithful also in much
the latter rain. Amen. What are you
doing now with whatever spirit you have?
If God has given you a thimble full of
the spirit, what are you doing with it?
If you're doing nothing, you will not
receive the bucket of the the latter
rain.
You've shown God no reason why he should
grant you the latter rain. What are you
doing now? Then God can empower you to
do more via the latter end, which is the
Holy Ghost. Amen. And amen. Now, I'm
going to, you know, give the opportunity
to anyone here that is on Zoom. If you
have a question on the topic, yes, on
the topic of the mystery of godliness,
feel free to unmute now. Okay, I see
sister Alana Kashi has raised her hand.
Ask your question, my attorney.
Happy Sabbath.
Okay. I just have a question in regards
to what you were saying before. You said
that, if I heard it correctly, Uhhuh. Is
it that people are not like people
themselves are not the latter rain? No,
the latter rain is a reference to the
Holy Spirit.
The latter isn't literal rain. It's a
symbolic expression referring to a
greater outpouring of the Holy Spirit.
The apostles in the upper room in uh in
Acts chapter 2, they were not the early
reign. The spirit came upon them. No
human being can be the latter rain. The
latter end is a reference to the Holy
Spirit, the third member of the Godhead.
It is he in us that empowers us to do
the work. So no, people are not the
latter. People are used and empowered by
the spirit of God. The latter rain
simply refers an outpouring of the Holy
Spirit on a much wider scale than was
witnessed in Acts chapter 2 called the
early reign or the former reign.
Thank you. Oh, you're very welcome.
All right. All right. So, we are out of
time. We're out of time. Yes.
Oh, sorry. I have a question. It will be
a short one.
Well, Dr. May, go ahead.
What? Well, Kaskky, what do you say? Oh,
go ahead. Go ahead. If it's Yes. Yes.
Yes. All right, sister. If you have your
question on the subject, feel free to go
ahead. Okay. Um, so there was a
discussion that I was listening to
recently and well I I just wanted to
pose it to Elder Skate. It was talking
about um where the Bible says that
Christ Jesus was without sin meaning
that he had never committed any sin in
his life. So in this discussion um one
person said that but you know children
they um born with selfishness and and
sometimes they are you know selfish and
that is sin. So how did Jesus not go
through that stage? And one of the
pastors in that discussion said that
Jesus was born converted meaning that um
as when we become converted we surrender
our lives to Christ and Christ is in
control. So um he guides our every
thought, word and action. So Jesus was
born converted. So his life was already
surrendered to God the father. um by the
time he was born and that is why he was
without sin. I'd like to hear um what
you have to say about this because I'm
not sure
whether to to believe this or not. Mhm.
Thank you. Jesus Christ is our example.
Let me show you from the Bible how he
is. Go to John 13. Let's read 13-15.
When we establish he's our example,
we'll get further into answering your
question. John 13. 13-15
Ye call me master and lord and ye say
well for so I am if I then your lord and
master have washed your feet also ought
to wash one another's feet for I have
given you an example that ye should do
as I have done all right Jesus said
here's an example do as I have done okay
let us go to first Peter chapter two
from verse one. Papa from verse 21. 1
Peter chapter 21 reading from verse 21.
Okay. For even here unto were ye called
because Christ also suffered for us,
leaving us an example that ye should
follow in his steps. Again, we have the
Bible says suffering wrongfully is an
example Jesus set for us. It's a
difficult thing to do being falsely
accused. But from verse 18 on to verse
20, we're told, "Is thank worthy with
God that a man suffer wrongfully."
Christ said, "I suffered wrongfully."
This is an example for you. Don't go
fighting the one abusing you
necessarily, but take it quietly. Now,
let's look at Christ being an example
again. Go to John 15.
Read verse 12.
This is my commandment that ye love one
another as I have loved. Ah, now that's
an example again. You love each other as
I have loved you. Now go to Revelation 3
and let's read verse 21.
To him that overcomemeth will I grant to
sit with me in my throne even as I also
overcame. So Christ overcame. We're to
overcome as he overcame by the same
power. He is our example. Go to John 17.
Let's read verse 11 of verse 22.
This is the issue of unity now. Oneness.
And the glory which thou gavest me, I
have given them that they may be one
even as we are one. Yes. So consistently
the Bible tells us Christ in so many
ways came to us as an example
of what we can be through the same power
that sustained him. Now let's go back to
the question that Christ uh was sinless.
The Bible tells us he never sinned. Of
course, we're dealing with a mystery at
every level, but there's biblical
evidence. Very straight. Christ never
sinned. Let's go to Let's go back to 1
Peter chapter 2. Let's read verse 22.
22 Who did no sin. Okay, let me just go
there. Yes. Who did no sin, neither was
Gile
who did no sin, neither was guile found
in his mouth. Jesus did no sin. Let's go
to first Peter 1. Read verse 19 and
verse 20. But with the precious blood of
Christ, the foundation of the world. No,
no, just read that.
Yeah, I was like mixing with the next.
But with the precious blood of Christ,
as of a lamb without blemish and without
he was sinless. Go to John chapter 8.
In which verse? Four and five.
They say verses four and five. Pap 45.
Oh, 45. There we go. 45.
And because I tell you the truth, Mhm.
ye believe me not. Mhm. Which, this is
verse 46. Which of you convincth me of
sin? Nobody can. Go to John 14.
Read verse 30.
hereafter
I will not talk much with you for this
pr for the prince of this world cometh
and hath nothing I think me so the Bible
is clear over Christ never sinned now go
to John 8:29 let's read from verse 29
and he that sent me is with me the
father hath not left me alone. Mhm. For
I do always those things that please
him. So we can infer from the point
where he reached the knowledge of good
and evil, Christ always chose to do what
was right in the sight of God. Now a
savior had to be sinless.
Jesus could have chosen to sin. He
clearly chose not. If Christ had sinned
once, he could not have been a savior
because Adam was excluded from Eden
because he sinned once. He just sinned
once and he was excluded. The second
Adam could not sin once because the
first Adam failed because of one sin.
The second Adam could not have sinned
once. He had to be sinless. So we have
to believe that Jesus was so well taught
by his mother
that he grew up.
I look forward to meeting Mary in the
kingdom to ask her how did she do it to
raise that boy in such a way that he
never ever chose to sin. I say again
while we can't answer all questions we
know this the lamb that the Israelites
had to bring. Let's go to uh Leviticus
chapter 1. Let's look at that lamb. We
read from verse three.
If his offering be a burnt sacrifice of
the herd, let him offer a male without
blemish. Yes. Um read verse 10.
And if his offering be of the flocks,
namely of the sheep or of the goats, for
a burnt sacrifice, he shall bring it a
male without. All right. So, we're
taught this the lamb represented Christ,
the savior. The savior had to be
sinless.
Jesus never chose to sin. Now let me
talk about the carnal nature. The car
Jesus took our fallen weak nature. The
carnal nature is itself not a moral sin.
In other words, you don't choose a
carnal nature. You're born that way. And
God does not hold you responsible for
that. That is not the sin that causes
people to be lost. It is acting on that
nature and choosing to disobey God. Let
me say it again. The carnal nature is
not a sin. I'm not saying it's good.
It's not a sin. But Christ came with our
weak nature. If uh Hebrews chapter 2:14
or verse 11, it tells us that Christ
became one of us. For both he that
sanctifith, and they which are
sanctified are all of one, for which
cause he's not ashamed to call them
brethren. I have the same nature. We're
one. Hebrews 2:14. For as much then as
the children are partakers of flesh and
blood, he also himself likewise took
part of the same, that through death he
might destroy him that had the power of
death, that is the devil, and deliver
them who through fear of death were all
their lifetime subject to bondage.
Listen to verse 16. For verily he took
not on him the nature of angels, he took
on him the seed of Abraham. And you
check the seeds of Abraham. There's some
very shady characters. Jesus took our
weak nature and in that nature,
empowered by the Holy Ghost, he lived a
life above sin. Our savior had to be
sinless or he could not have been a
savior. Let me say it again. The Bible
calls Christ the last Adam or the second
Adam, the second man, Eve's husband, the
first Adam. The first Adam fell because
of one sin. The second Adam in order to
overcome he had to conquer completely
and he could not have sinned. Christ was
sinless.
Outside of that he could not have been
our savior. You cannot have a savior who
has sinned because then he would need a
savior. But again there are mysteries
that we cannot now completely unfold.
But there is evidence that can point us
in the right direction.
Jesus Christ never sinned.
Amen. Amen. Amen.
All right. First John chapter 3.
First John chapter 3. Read verse three.
I'm sorry, Papa Ski. Which verse? First
John chapter 3 verse three. Verse three.
Okay.
And every man that hath this hope in
him. Read two. Read from two. Okay.
Beloved, now we are the sons of God, and
it doth not yet appear what we shall be,
but we know that when he shall appear,
we shall be like him, for we shall see
him as he is. And we shall be like him,
not in his divinity. No one can be
divine unless you only go is divine. We
shall be like him in his human nature,
you see, which he shares with us. we
shall be like him. So it is possible for
someone to while only Christ never
sinned. But those of us who have sinned
through the blood of Christ, we can come
to the place where we stop sinning. We
stop choosing to sin. We prefer death
over sin. Death over dishonor.
Christ never sin. Don't let that thought
cross your mind that he sinned. Please.
He never sinned. That's why he can
function as a savior. You see, when the
animal was brought to be sacrificed, it
had to be examined. If one fault was
found, it was rejected. Christ's
sacrifice had to be examined by the
father and he found it acceptable
because there was no sin in the sun. If
he had seen one sin, that would have
been a catastrophe. We would have no
savior.
Next question. Amen. So, Sister Alana, I
will permit you to ask this question. Is
this on the subject?
I believe so. I hope so. Yes. Yes, it
is. Okay.
Um, just going back to my question uh
about the the the latter rain and the
former reign. I just wanted to ask
because in Micah se in Micah 5 verse 7
to8 it talks about
um from the Lord as the showers upon the
grass but I guess like my question is
just asking about is there a connection
between that do are we the do in the
former rain if I got that correct or is
it the latter rain I just wanted to
understand like where our placement is
within
those two types of rain.
Should I read our placement is we are
recipients.
The apostles 2,000 years ago were
recipients of the early reign. He came
upon them. They were filled with the
Holy Ghost. The same will happen to us
to a larger degree. We will be filled
more powerfully, more fully with uh if
such a thing is possible with the Holy
Ghost. Our place in this is that we will
be the recipients
of this power called the latter rain
which really is the Holy Spirit who can
be everywhere at the same time and
empowering people to issue that loud
cry. Nothing about us
is of itself the the latter rain.
Nothing about us is the latter rain. The
latter rain is the vine gift of Holy
Spirit. Nothing about us is the latter.
not the rain to do nothing. We are the
recipients
of the latter reign of the Holy Ghost
uses us to do the work of the loud cry
calling people out of Babylon. And papas
because I see sister Alana asked a
question and then watch and pray 2.0 act
also asks about Micah 5:7. So I just
want to read it. Yes. All right. We can
just clarify. So Micah 5:7. And the
remnant of Jacob shall be in the midst
of many people as a do from the Lord, as
the showers upon the grass that territh
not for man, nor waitth for the sons of
men. Well, that's fine. You see, that's
fine. What does Jew do? You know, Jew
nourishes the grass. But Jesus said,
"You're the light of the world." You
see, these are symbolic expressions. We
are the light of the world. That's what
the Bible says. Jesus says that ma
Matthew 5 verse4
we're the light of the world you see he
says you're the salt so we have light we
have salt we have dune are you following
me
we are simply the instruments through
which Christ through his holy spirit
reaches the world with the truth the
light you see in John 8:12 Jesus says I
am the light of the world in Matthew
5:14 he says ye the light he's not
conting himself he's simply saying when
he says aware that you're the light of
the world. You're my light. I'm shining
out of you. We have no light of
ourselves. The biblical light is a
divine thing. Let me say it again.
Biblical light is a divine quality. No
human being possesses a divine quality
naturally. So when Jesus says, "Ye light
of the world," that light is really his.
So we read, "Let your light so shine
before men that they may see your good
works." The good works brought about by
the power of the Holy Spirit. You and I
have no light naturally.
So when you're the light of the world,
you are the reflector of the light of
Jesus. You're the salt of the earth.
Then you are preserver. You are
preservative. And a Christian anywhere
should be a preservative.
When the angels came to destroy Sodom
and Gomorrah,
uh Lot told the angels, can I go to this
city? The angel said, yes, but move. I
need to do some destruction where you
are, but I cannot do it as long as
you're here. In that sense, Lot was a
preservative
and God had to get him out so he can
destroy because he cannot destroy the
righteous with the wicked. And so we are
preservative salt. We are light in the
sense that Christ is the preservative,
not us, Christ, but he works through us.
Christ is the light. He works through
us. So we're light, we're salt, we're
due, we're rain sense that we are a
blessing to people. That's all it is.
But no human being can be the Holy
Ghost.
[Music]
Yes. Very well said. You know, and I
just to add on, Papa Ski, in verse 8, it
says, "The remnant of Jacob shall be
among the Gentiles in the midst of many
people as a lion among the beast." You
know, we know Jesus is the line of the
tribe of Judah. We are not the
expression. Exact symbolic expression.
Yeah. Yes. So, we are definitely out of
time. I know in dear Rogers you asked
the question. Oh my but we are we are
out of time. And brother Brandon we
actually spoke about I think you asked
about uh the value of Christ maintaining
his humanity after the resurrection. We
actually did a whole Q&A on the humanity
of Christ and also on the divinity of
Christ. I'll put those links in the in
the comments of this live stream. So
those answers to those questions, well
the question that you have asked,
brother Brandon, are in those videos.
Okay. Um,
we must close now. I'm so sorry, Sister
Indira. I will What was your question?
Indira, what's her question?
Her question is it connected to the
subject? It's more on the I believe it's
on the latter rain. How will we know
that we have the latter or early reign?
How will we know we have the early
latter reign? Well, by their fruits you
shall know them.
It was clear that the apostles had some
kind of power. They began to speak in
tongues which had never happened before.
It was surprised to them unto the
listeners. They were really shocked. The
fruits that the the spirit produces
would be evidence that we have the
latter rain. The fruits.
We won't walk around saying I have the
latter rain. We'll just find ourselves
doing the work of God unselfishly with
no regard for us simply for the glory of
God.
Amen. Amen. And amen. All right. So that
puts the caps down. Let me ask the
sister, the person, how how do you know
you have the the early reign which is
which is right now? How do you know? Are
you doing anything for God? Are you
working for him? Are you trying to send
souls? Do you have Bible studies? What
are you doing? How is is there any
evidence you have the early reign?
I don't want an answer to it. I'm simply
asking the question, what evidence do
you have you have the early reign far
less the latter?
Amen. Amen. You know, this is this this
is why the mystery of godliness has to
be revealed in us and why we you know,
we spoke about the import necessity of
the Holy Spirit and the study of the
scriptures to be able to understand this
mystery of godliness which we
established is Jesus. And we will
continue to study this for eternity. And
I'm sure if it were possible for this
live stream to go on forever just to ask
questions, it literally would go on
forever for us to just even attempt to
uncover what the mystery of godliness is
because we can't find out God. Can we by
searching find out God? No. No. But
what's must we stop searching? We have
to keep searching. We must keep on
searching. We must Let me also say that
I think your viewers need to know that
you completed your medical studies and
you now what's the word? A resident. Is
it Rochester somewhere in a family
medicine is it? So you're now on the
ward saving life for whom Jesus shed his
blood. They need to understand that
in addition to your commitment to the
gospel you have taken care of your
studies which is an example for people
serving the church should not mean that
you can be mediocre in your studies.
You're an example of good work
academically, good work spiritually. The
Lord is blessing you. Your leaders need
to, your listeners need to know you're
now a resident at a prestigious program
and the Lord will take you through that
as he took you through medical school.
And God bless you. I'm proud of you.
Amen. Thank you, Papa. Thank you. You
make my heart my heart happy. You know,
God is good. God, that's all I can say.
God is good. And he gives I like God
very much. He's a nice person. Yes, he
is. And that actually reminds me because
uh actually perfect segue. I've been
behind friends. You know, as Papovski
said, you know, it's uh it's it's not
necessarily easy, you know, juggling all
of this, but God gives us grace to do it
for his glory. You all had asked me to
do to share how is it that I balance
medicine and ministry. So, God willing,
July 26th, all right, at 3:00 p.m.
Eastern Standard Time, we're going to be
talking about methods or the
methodology, medicine and ministry, how
it has manifested in my life. So, I hope
to see you all then July 26 at 3:00 p.m.
Eastern Standard Time. So, feel free to
take a screenshot and save the date.
We'll be having a discussion and it'll
be a live stream, so you can ask me your
questions and by God's grace, I'll
answer as best I can.
All right. Well, Papa Speed, I thank you
for your time once again. Dear God bless
you in every possible way. Ah, thank you
so very much. I pray the Lord will Yes.
Thank you. May the Lord continue to
bless you and give you strength and
grace and also keep Sister SK safe.
Thank you and your home suite. God
bless. Thank you so much for your time.
Welcome. Amen. And to those of you that
have joined on the various platforms on
Zoom, YouTube, Facebook, Twitch,
Instagram, we're actually not on Twitch
anymore. Your interaction has been
amazing. Thank you for asking your
questions. Thank you for listening.
Sister Alana, thank you for putting
those uh scriptures that we mentioned as
well in the Zoom chat so that we can
keep up. Brother Israel, thank you again
for joining all the way from Ghana and
you're still here. God bless you. Using
rechargeable battery uh battery powered
lights uh so that we can see you today.
So, thank you for being here and for
filling in. Amen. Amen. Amen. God bless
you, Elder.
H God bless you, Elder Sk. Oh, God bless
you even more. God bless you. God bless
you. Amen.
Let me say this. There's coming a
blackout of truth on this earth.
Mhm.
Men will when they've exhausted all when
they've abused the mercies of God, they
will be a blackout of truth. They will
go north south looking for it, but the
time will be passed. And so people need
to find the truth now. And I'm saying
that because there's a blackout in your
country. There'll be a blackout of the
truth before Jesus Christ comes. But
only after he has given people enough
opportunities to find it and follow it.
May I hope the blackout comes to an end
very quickly.
Amen. Amen. Amen. God bless. Amen. God
bless you. And mom, thank you as well
for helping to moderate the chat and
putting those questions from our live
audience there so that I can see it. So,
thank you mom. You are missed. I'm no
longer in Brooklyn, but praise the Lord,
we can still interact. And I also want
to give a special shout out to my friend
Adore Remy who is also joining from
Brooklyn and has uh part uh has been
blessed by this session. So, thank you
for joining my sister. God bless you.
You are my MD M PH. So, so thank you.
Thank you for your ministry, your
friendship and for partaking in this
session. So, without further ado and
thank you sister Zonda, God be praised.
Without further ado, we'll move on. You
know, we spoke about the incarnation of
Christ, you know, the fact that he took
on human form and you know, he had to in
order to redeem us. If we look at
redemption in the Old Testament, it had
we had that person had to be redeemed by
a kingsman and Jesus became our elder
brother so that we could be saved. So,
Sister Chelsea Jack submitted this
video. Oh, come O come Emmanuel. That
she ministered on violin. I pray that
you are blessed as we reflect on the
condescension of Christ, his ministry on
our behalf, this eternal mystery that we
will study for salvation.
Excuse me, for eternity,
for our salvation. Amen.
[Music]
Hallelujah.
Heat. Heat.
[Music]
Last words.
Hallelujah.
[Music]
Yes.
Oh,
is Ro.
[Music]
Amen.
Amen. Thank you, Sister Chelsea Jack. I
just want to read the last stanza of
that hymn. Oh, come desire of nations.
Bind all peoples in one heart and mind.
Bid envy, strife, and quarrels to cease.
Fill the whole world with heaven's
peace. Rejoice, rejoice, Emmanuel.
shall come to thee, oh Israel.
Remember I said the one point or the
point I wanted to underscore in Papa's
response is that the mystery of
godliness should be revealed in us. And
it's not revealed by our might or our
power by God's spirit by the spirit of
Jesus Christ living in us. So may
Emmanuel not just come to us but be in
us so that we can fill the world with
his word of truth, salvation and hope.
So thank you for your presence here
today. Sister virtuous woman, thank you
for your kind words and constant
support. PapaKit uh sister Indira Rogers
said, "Pastor Ski, I truly appreciate
your mystery and wa and watch you
wherever you go." Uh, Brother Batist, I
don't know where Papa Sket will be next,
but I'm sure you'll find out. It will
likely be streamed maybe on to CBN or
some other platform or channel. So,
without further ado, I'm going to turn
it over to Brother Ashton Quashi, or as
I affectionately call him, my mom gave
him the name, Professor Ashton Quashi,
who will do our closing prayer. And, uh,
Sister Brown, the Zoom link was in the
description of the video. So moving
forward, that's where will be the
description of the video. Sorry I didn't
see it earlier or I would have put it in
the comments. But Professor Quashi, let
me highlight you and you will do our
closing prayer.
Are you able to unmute? Maybe not. Let
me uh Yeah. Okay, there we go.
Um, thanks.
Yeah, thanks Pastor Randy SK for
answering questions. We were truly
blessed. Let us pray as we do close in
prayer.
Dear God, thank you for your Sabbath
day. I pray that you help us to live a
life of faith in you and by doing so
that we can understand the mystery of
goldeness. As we look towards the end of
this world, let us by your grace live an
upright life so that we may like Abel,
Noah, Daniel, and the three Hebrew boys
and Jesus Christ who you were well
pleased in be reflected when us. Amen.
Amen. And amen.
Ah, praise the Lord. Praise the Lord.
Thank you, Professor Quashi. Professor
Quashi is only 13 years old, brothers
and sisters. I know he's got the voice
uh like a grown man. He's got the
Whintley Fif's voice, a voice like Papa
Ski. But praise the Lord, Professor
Ashen Quashi was here today. And I also
want to highlight him. Maybe I should
also add myself to the spotlight so you
all can see me and not just hear my
voice. But Professor Quashi also
recently dedicated his life to the Lord
and was baptized. Praise the Lord. The
Lord is still calling young men like
Professor Kwashi and young women to give
their hearts to Jesus. So, thank you,
Professor Kashi, for consecrating your
life to the Lord and I pray that he will
continue to use you to further his
gospel as you continue preaching and
singing and ministering for him.
Amen. Amen. Thank you. Amen. You're
welcome. Amen. Amen. All right, brothers
and sisters, thank you all for your
presence. Sister Cleo, it's great to see
you. Thank you everyone for being here.
Uh God willing, I will see you all at
our next session. In fact, I'm just
going to share it one more time so that
we are all on the same page. This will
be by God's grace, July 26th at 3:00
p.m. Eastern Standard Time. We're
talking about methods, medicine, and
ministry. How has God done it through my
life? And this may not be the way he
does it through your life. This is just
my personal testimony. So I hope to see
you then. Take care and God bless.
All right. Bye-bye.
Bye, Sister Danisha. God bless you for
the opportunity given me. Ah, praise
God. Thank you, brother Israel, for
being willing and taking up the mantle.
Amen. Amen. I really appreciate it. My
pleasure. Amen.
Oh, Sister Alana is saying, "Stay safe
in the power outage."
And I guess anyone else, if you want to
unmute and chat, I actually haven't
stopped the stream yet, but if you want
to just say a couple words, feel free to
unmute if you're here on the Zoom and,
you know, just interact.
Okay.
All right then. All right.